[Music]
Aurora is not with me, she hasn't gone back to
sleep at home
because it costs so much to notify her if she doesn't.  We have to
prepare ourselves not to sleep until we
catch him the police want to talk to
the teachers they will not be suspecting us they
are not capable of being a neighbor friend you
think it was his father it is known that
they were doing the Institute at that time
but forget that I arrived on  The case is
confidential, dad, but you know I
can help you
[Music]
Julia, please be very careful with
that guy, are you going to tell me what's going on?
[ __ ] it wasn't a good idea to come
when your mom died
we're in this together
the town is going to blow up
[Applause]
[Music]